all right ladies we're at the hollywood
beauty awards you all look beautiful i
want to talk about the importance of
recognizing the importance of styling
and hair and makeup we're bringing light
to this so many of us feel comfortable
in front of a camera because of so many
very important people here just talk
about why this night is important to you
i mean the
behind the scenes of anything has always
been a fascinating world to me they're
always the most important people that
make this show happen make make the
world go around in the entertainment
industry and i think it was so important
for me to be able to come here and
celebrate these two um because
honestly like aside from just doing my
hair and makeup and and styling glam
teams are and especially these two are
like the heart and soul of like my life
they're my best friends like
i think a lot of people will tell you
that like they just they become your
everything like we grow together we have
babies together we we you know there's
just so much in our lives and there's
hard times and there's great times but
they're like always there for you and
it's just so important that that these
people that we spend so much of our days
with are good people and and it's i'm so
happy to be here for them kristy i want
to ask you something you've been such a
powerhouse talking about
certain things in your life
ivf your sobriety you have been a leader
to some people in my family and fans all
over do you care to comment how are
those things going
great i'm gosh what am i now i like lost
count of the sobriety journey but
honestly these you know what's funny is
like these things are very weird for me
because i'm so used to getting so like
just like hammered at these at these
things
awards season i very much connect to
enjoying yourself and having champagne
and
but also like i also connected with
those feelings of like immense regret or
like stupid moments like i can't believe
i said that or i can't believe i did
that and i'm so embarrassed and so it's
so nice not to have those feelings
anymore um but yeah everything
everything is good i finished my my ivf
part so i feel so much healthier and so
much better with that but but yeah the
the sobriety thing is fun and we'll see
i'm gonna make it through this
awards how does it feel we are here for
y'all tonight i know it's very different
we're so awkward we feel so weird we're
trying to learn how to be on this side
of the camera yeah that's hard
with how uncomfortable they are like i
love it i feel like a proud mommy and
i'm like you guys always practice posing
and doing all those things scariest part
about tonight for youtube
this part yeah i like honestly just
being in front of it because i'm so used
to be behind yeah i love behind i'm like
you look great you can do this and now
i'm like oh oh no
i had bad anxiety like i really before
we left like it's just been a while and
i was like oh my goodness like i'm not
used to
this part of it it's so weird it's like
real again yeah it is things are
happening again
yeah well let's talk glam process i want
to know do you have rituals do you have
um music you listen to snacks you like
to eat talk to me i mean all we do is
eat while we go
that's all we do
uh we try new things all the time
there's a lot of like collaboration
talking about what you know they're
feeling for the day and we're feeling
for the day and how it's all going to
come together and there's always that
beginning part where we're like catching
up because we've been seeing each other
since yesterday
actually shocked that there's always so
much to talk about yeah i don't know i
know like time goes back like oh my god
we only have an hour left and we've been
sitting there for two hours
like my therapy i'm like struggling to
find what to talk about and then with
you guys i'm like oh my god this
happened thank you so much
hollywood beauty awards should also be
the hollywood therapy awards because the
beauty the beauty artists in this town
they here in earful don't they oh
beyonce yeah we walk in the door
everyone has a story of you guys i have
to tell you this today every single day
and like the crying that happened i mean
there's truly so much like life happens
and it happens and and they're here and
they've seen everything that's why
they're just like truly my entire heart
let me ask you this what are your kids
when your kids see you go through this
process are they
here for it are they like this is so
cool and crazy luna is obsessed luna's
obsessed with them like
truly like we're gonna approve
there's really no better feeling than
people you love like loving your kids
and being good to your children and my
kids love them so much like this is
miles girlfriend he just read
he broke up he broke up with her for
like a minute but they got back together
yesterday what caused the breakup yeah
it was all the joke i guess yeah that's
what i told you he was like you ate all
of his fruit loops and it's over yeah he
was just kidding he
said um let's talk about i like this a
lot so some people when they're getting
glammed up there's certain things they
know they won't look good in they know
they don't want is there anything like
that for chrissy
she hates royal blue i'll never bring
like a full royal blue anything that's a
good question nobody ever like yeah um
no keyholes
paid a keyhole a cold shoulder okay
that's so weird i have a cold children
like no it's just a guilt
i do hate a cold shoulder i don't know
why i don't know i mean they're very
specific so i'm just like no we'll never
see it we'll never bring it are there
any superstitious things you do or don't
do on a night of glam getting ready for
a big show or night out i don't know do
we no i mean maybe there's things we've
learned the hard way that we've seen
photos of and we're like we're not gonna
do that again but not a lot of those dry
powders yeah yeah yeah
yeah we actually don't have like crazy
like we haven't done like a crazy
mistake yet yeah let's do it i mean a
lot of zippers break
there has been a lot of zippers that
have broken
oh yeah styling is always my bad
shoes have broke all the time i'm in
there
taping back shoes together figuring
jerry rigging some shoes
i'm always really bad with clothing like
the makeup holds up really well it's the
clothing that's just like all goes to
hell yeah we were talking about how many
times i've ridden in the back of a car
just so that a belt doesn't break and
everyone else is like leaving and i'm
like i'm just okay i can't get in i'm
hiding to get through the door
[Music]